[Music]
the umbrella academy is one of the most
popular series on the streaming service
netflix the third season has been out
since the end of june and after the
season finale fans are wondering what
will happen next with the series indeed
netflix has recently commissioned the
fourth season and it seems that this
will also be the last one in the course
of announcing season four showrunner and
series creator steve blackman promised
fans a series finale that would have
them on the edge of their seats until
the final minutes the announcement
delighted much of the fan community
after all there are still some
unanswered questions to be resolved
including the mysterious post-credits
scene at the end of the third season
nothing is officially known yet
regarding the actor's return but we
assume that tom hopper david castaneda
emmy raver lampman aidan gallagher
justin h min and elliot page will once
again portray their characters as for
the exact release date of season 4 sadly
we don't know anything about it yet
fans and critics alike were very
thrilled with the third season of the
boys a few months ago with jensen eckles
and his role as soldier boy a
supernatural star was already added to
the cast and now the next actor from the
series which ended in 2020 has already
been confirmed from the upcoming fourth
season as told by the hollywood reporter
jeffrey dean morgan is set to join the
cast in the near future the 56 year old
played the role of john winchester in
supernatural and can also be seen
starring as negan in the walking dead in
fact these are not the only two former
supernatural actors since jim beaver who
embodies robert singer and the boys was
also previously featured there for this
very reason many fans are amused by the
casting and already suspect a crossover
between the two series after all
showrunner eric kripke is also the
creator of supernatural and seems to
have been deeply impressed by some
people sadly it is not apparent yet
which character jeffrey dean morgan is
going to play though many are banking on
tech night like iron man tech knight
wears a high-tech suit and is regarded
as a wacky sex-addicted parody of the
marvel superhero you could definitely
imagine morgan in the role however
nothing has been officially confirmed
yet the same goes for the release date
of the boy season 4 but we will keep you
up to date as usual
at the end of july we were able to see
the first unofficial shots of the
filming of godzilla vs kong 2. the
footage shows numerous people fleeing
from an invisible monster on an
australian beach according to reports a
scene of the copacabana and rio de
janeiro will be shown here in the
finished film which monster rushed there
on the extras however is not known as of
yet in the recently published synopsis
it is stated that godzilla and kong just
like in the previous film will once
again fight together against a mighty
enemy that threatens not only the earth
but also the very existence of the two
giant creatures moreover the story of
the titans will be told in greater
detail and the mysteries of skull island
will be revealed back in the cast of
rebecca hall is dr eileen andrews brian
tyree henry is bernie hayes and kaylee
hoddle as eileen's stepdaughter gia also
added to the current cast are three new
actors joining them are the batman actor
alex fearns shang chi and the legend of
the ten rings actress falachan and
rachel house who starred in cowboy bebop
for example in addition to the three new
and three long-known actors beauty and
the beast actor dan stevens will also
have a part it is still unclear whether
millie bobby brown alexander skarsgard
or kyle chandler will be playing a role
in the sequel again we are looking
forward to learning more about the still
untitled godzilla vs kong sequel which
will be released in cinemas on march
15th 2024
actor sir ben kingsley became world
famous not only for his role as itzhak
stern in the classic film schindler's
list in recent years the 78 year old has
also been able to impress in more
contemporary productions such as shutter
island the third night at the museum
movie and also in iron man 3 as the
powerful enemy mandarin
now the brit is heading back to the mcu
more specifically to the upcoming wonder
man series as variety reports disney
announced that kingsley will once again
embody the character of trevor slattery
aka mandarin in the series
kingsley was last seen in the mcu movie
shangley and the legend of the ten rings
in the same role albeit with
comparatively little screen time this is
now set to change as reports all
indicate that kingsley's part in wonder
man will be quite big
another interesting aspect of the series
is its planned style which according to
rumors will be a satire on show business
in the original comic wonder man is the
son of a big industrialist who gains his
superpowers including speed endurance
reflexes and strength through chemical
and radioactive experiments conducted by
baron zemo
initially
man is the declared enemy of the
avengers however in the course of the
story eventually joins them
behind the camera shang chi director
destin daniel [ __ ] is responsible for
directing while the screenplay is
written by brooklyn nine-nine author
andrew guest a release date on disney
plus is currently unknown as is much of
the cast or plot so we'll just keep
waiting for new info on wonder man
there is no good news for fans of
aquaman in the lost kingdom at the
moment after the drama around batgirl
and scooby-doo warner additionally
announced that aquaman in the lost
kingdom will not be running in theaters
on the planned date originally december
2022 then march 2023 was intended for
the sequel's debut however as those in
charge announced a few days ago we can
now only count on a december 2023
release reports say that the
post-production of the blockbuster in
particular is a colossal task that will
require more time than first thought
also as we have recently come to know
the finances of the parent company
warner brothers discovery equally played
a key factor in this decision for 2022
the film giant is said to only have
budget left for a mere two film releases
black adam on october 21st and don't
worry darling on september 23rd in 2023
the situation looks a little better as
there are at least a few high-profile
films to look forward to shazam fury of
the gods the flash blue beetle and
finally aquaman in the lost kingdom the
aquaman sequel will be released in
theaters on december 25th 2023
fans of the video game series bioshock
had to wait many years into reliable
information about the planned netflix
adaptation finally leaked out in fact
the film has been in the works for many
years but at the time the collaboration
between the intended director gore
verbinski and the film studio universal
was put on ice only a few weeks before
the then planned start of shooting as we
know since february 2022 work on
bioshock has been resumed and a director
has now also been found as netflix
announced via twitter the hunger games
director francis lawrence will take over
the directing for the streaming service
however before the 51 year old can get
started with the bioshock movie
adaptation the upcoming the hunger games
the ballad of songbirds and snakes which
is scheduled for release in november
2023 must first be finished until then
there is also plenty of time for blade
runner 2049 screenwriter michael green
as he is currently hard at work on the
bioshock script consisting of three
parts released between 2007 and 2013 the
video game series is a combination of a
role playing game and survival horror
set in a dystopian futuristic world the
first two parts are about the partially
destroyed underwater city of rapture
which is nothing less than a failed
social experiment from which the
protagonist jack who has ended up there
must try to escape during his time in
rapture he uncovers numerous secrets and
provides help to one last survivor only
in the third part is there a change of
scenery which is done between rapture
and the city of colombia colombia is not
an underwater city but one floating in
the sky where the protagonist finds
himself at the beginning of the 20th
century there too unrest and riots
dominate the actually lovely cityscape
what all three games have in common is
that they bring together a very large
fan base that appreciates not only the
futuristic visuals but above all the
complex profound and sometimes even
philosophical storyline exactly what
netflix's bioshock movie will be about
is still entirely unclear but it will
presumably take quite a while before the
filming starts
many fans were looking forward to star
trek iv which was supposed to be
released next year however this will
probably not be the case anymore because
director matt shakman has dropped out of
the project without further ado as
announced a few days ago the official
reason are scheduling issues with the 47
year old who is still in talks for
fantastic four from phase six of the mcu
meanwhile those responsible are likely
to be on the lookout for a suitable
successor so that the planned release
date does not have to be pushed back too
much in fact paramount has been having
major problems with the planned star
trek movie for quite some time so that
shackman's departure is likely to be
just the tip of the iceberg at the
beginning of the year the responsible
parties created a stir when they
announced not only the development of
star trek iv but also the direct signing
of some great actors the trouble was
that the actors around chris pine carl
urban and zoe saldana themselves were
unaware of this as none of them had
signed a contract at the time
unfortunately shakman's departure marks
the first news in a long time about star
trek iv so we have no idea which actors
are actually part of the official cast
at this point if we're up to paramount's
preference they will get the entire crew
of the uss kelvin including the
aforementioned actors in front of the
camera currently there are also rumors
about the casting of euphoria actress
sydney sweeney who is said to be in
talks with paramount about a new star
trek movie although it is not sure
whether this also concerns star trek iv
a new release date is not available yet
however we will keep updating you on the
latest news
and that was the news for this week if
you still haven't had enough take a look
at our big movie preview of sonic the
hedgehog 3 in our new originals episode
you can learn everything there is to
know about the sequel to the animated
spectacle be sure to check it out
[Music]